new data suggests lack of sleep early in
life can raise the risk of heart disease
later research in the journal Pediatrics
connects insufficient sleep in young
teens to cardiac risk factors including
high blood pressure abnormal cholesterol
and obesity in the book why we sleep
unlocking the power of sleep and dreams
Matthew Walker says sleep is
underestimated as a prevention for
disease it's published by Scribner &
imprint of Simon & Schuster division of
CBS Walker his director of the Center
for human sleep science at the
University of California Berkeley
welcome sleep as a country we have not
been to it and it's true the study found
that three fewer than 3% of kids get the
recommended amount of sleep so how does
this affect their hearts
yeah it's frightening less than 3%
getting the recommended and necessary 9
hours of sleep a night and what they
found is that those under slept teens
had worse health outcomes they had
larger waist lines more abdominal fat
but they were also heading on a path
towards hypertension high blood pressure
and we see that same type of heart
impact in adults
I should note as well one example there
is a global experiment performed on 1.6
billion people across 70 countries twice
a year and it's called daylight savings
time and what we see is that in the
spring when we lose just one hour of
sleep there is a subsequent 24 percent
increase in heart attacks the following
day so I think the the message here is
that without sleep we become heart
broken in the quite literal medical
sense of the definition what do we mean
when we say we've got no good night
sleep is it just the hours is it getting
up at the same time every day you know
what should we prioritize when we're
thinking about what makes up a good
night's sleep so regularity is key going
to bed at the same time waking up at the
same time no matter what but I think
also it's not just about quantity that's
what we've been discovering and that
sort of mentioned a lot in the book it's
also about quality so for example even
if you're getting eight hours but you're
waking up many more times throughout the
night or you're not getting that deep
sleep in fact coming back to heart
health what we've discovered recently
that deep sleep provides the very best
form of natural blood pressure
medication that you could ever wish for
and that's sleep essentially both
quantity and quality they are the elixir
of life and I you know I often say I
think that sleep is almost sort of like
the Swiss Army knife of health in that
no matter what the ailment it's more
than likely that sleep has a tool within
the box that will see you well to
measure the quality of sleep many have
turned to technology right and mart
watches what have you do you support
those devices that metric quality and do
they measure quality accurately those
devices right now are somewhat accurate
in terms of quantifying how much sleep
that you got but in terms of separating
that quality of deep sleep from dream
sleep right now they're not at the
precision level of accuracy that they
want or that we want will they get there
in the next three to five years I
suspect so and I think that quantified
self-movement of tracking will actually
enable people and empower people to
bring back sleep plentifully into their
health equation I really do feel Matthew
more and more people are talking about
sleep or lack of it maybe I notice it
because I know I'm not getting enough
it's like you don't notice tires on sale
until you need it yeah do you do you
think that most people don't really
understand how serious this is
I do the lack of it because in the lead
be honest said or John said it's you you
say it's underestimated as a prevention
for disease yeah I think sleep is
probably the neglected stepsister in the
health conversation of today I think
we've done a good job regarding physical
activity and diet but sleep has remained
out there in the cold and that's
surprising to me because sleep is not
the third pillar of good health it's
actually the foundation on which those
two other things sit so for example if
you're dieting and you're trying to lose
weight but you're not getting enough
sleep 70% of all that weight that you
lose will come from lean muscle mass and
not fat because your body becomes stingy
in giving up that fat when you are
underslept
do you think it's a series of smoking um
I think we perhaps are with sleep where
we were with smoking 50 years ago in
that we had
all of the science and it was right
there for the public discussion but it
not yet adequately sort of percolate it
out into policy or even just public
wisdom and I think that's part of the
reason I sort of wrote the book to try
and get that knowledge out there and
empower P it is definitely not a luxury
it is a necessity it's a biological
disaster thank you so much you're very
well